the truth is I wanted to put I wanted to
do this on camera I wanted to talk to
you on camera in for two reasons one
because you and I both shared the desire
to for other veterans who may see this
so that they understand that there that
there are others like them who shared
their experiences that there they're not
by themselves but rather they're part of
a community still and whether it's
Galant view or another organization that
there are people in their community who
they can call up and say can I talk I'm
struggling I I hope that this saves a
few lives you know just just long enough
that someone can make a phone call to
somebody who would take care of them you
know just that that little gap and also
to people who aren't veterans to try and
learn more about the importance of real
human bonds
you